warning spoilers for infinity war
incoming
[Music]
look at all the youtube channels just
starving for clicks
too many channels to watch them all but
to snuff them all out at once
instantly that is a mercy with a snap of
my
fingers half of all youtube channels
will disappear
at last i can sit contentedly and watch
us
what's going on oh no no they all
had second channels
hello internet welcome to film theory
where let's be honest here for a second
a top
youtube channel getting dusted overnight
is probably the
single best way to get people
re-interested when they were just
starting to get bored of the youtuber
you know what wasn't boring though
infinity war
i gotta be honest it was so much better
than i expected
it was such a well-balanced movie the
perfect mix of action
humor and drama all that and they
crammed 60 characters in without making
it feel rushed or bloated it was
so good it had to have had superman
wetting his tiny whities
or tiny reddies i suppose but perhaps
most impressive of all
was thanos easily one of marvel's best
villains
nay best characters for being this big
bad
mad titan he was surprisingly relatable
and sympathetic
well as much as he can be sympathetic
and relatable for someone looking to
wipe out half the population of the
galaxy
if you're still with us but haven't seen
the movie yet because all the theaters
are still sold out let me catch you up
thanos the giant purple uh blue
ah sorry pink doc fine thanos
the rainbow titan watched as this planet
became overpopulated and started to run
out of basic resources
while he suggested a random culling of
half his planet's population
the other titans found this suggestion
kinda mean
so they ignored it eventually the planet
couldn't find a solution and destroyed
itself in the process
leaving thanos with the universe's
biggest case of i
told you so so to prevent other planets
from experiencing the same fate
big papa thanos made it his life's work
to randomly eliminate half the life of
the universe he mentions that he's done
it once before on gamora's home planet
of zen and that it worked out pretty
well
uh since i don't have the clip from the
movie since it's still in theaters to
prove it uh here's a dramatic recreation
of that scene
i was a child when you took me i saved
you
it sounds like the grinch so i've been
smoking a lot lately okay
i saved you what
what's wrong with my thanos what do you
want my santa you're here do you want me
to be gamora and you be thanos here
let's do it that way then
i was a child when you took me i served
you
no no we were happy on my home plate
going to bed hungry scrounging for
scraps your planet was on the brink of
collapse
i was the one who stopped that you know
what's happened
since then the children born know
nothing but full bellies and
clear skies it's a paradise
because you murdered half the planet a
small price to pay
for salvation you're insane
and earth is next on his hit list at the
end of infinity war we
actually see thanos succeed though of
course that random culling process just
so happens to specifically target those
characters whose contracts aren't about
to expire but you know what we're gonna
give thanos the benefit of the doubt
here and assume that he isn't secretly
working for some dark secret overlord
but
here's the thing for as absolutely
insane as thanos plan
sounds and for as much as we as an
audience don't believe what he's saying
about the state of gomorrah's home world
if you stop
and look at the economics statistics and
historical precedents
thanos may actually be right
you heard that correctly when you run
the numbers it turns out that thanos the
mad titan
may not be as mad as you might think
first let's talk population growth since
that's the underlying driver of all the
economics here
there are two main population growth
models that exist today the exponential
growth model and the logistic growth
model the exponential model basically
says that as the population grows the
rate at which it grows will continue to
increase and get
faster basically doubling every
generation and this
kind of makes sense right if i have two
kids and each one of those two kids
have two kids now there's four those
four kids each themselves have two kids
and now there's eight
each generation doubles or in science
class how you learn that one bacteria
dividing every 20 minutes
could produce 5 000 billion billion
bacteria in just one day
then you leave class if you never touch
a doorknob again but you can see that
for humans this doesn't really work
we all have different numbers of kids or
no kids or we live in a place in the
world where it's illegal to have more
than one kid
as a result there's the logistic
population model where population growth
begins slowing at a certain point
reaching some type of upper limit called
the carrying capacity
usually this is the result of
environmental factors in the case of
bacteria it might be the walls of the
petri dish you just
run out of room and for a lot of
demographers the people who study human
populations
they believe we have a carrying capacity
too specifically around 11 to 12
billion people now that sounds like it's
a lot but remember we're at
7.3 billion people right now so we're
actually not that far away
the idea that we would slowly approach
the carrying capacity of earth was first
posited by 18th century demographer
thomas malthus if you want to learn more
about malthus and the philosophy of
thanos
watch the musical urine town anyone
anyone no no one's interested in a
delightful musical romp through a world
where you have to pay to pee
fine then watch the wisecrack channel
who did an excellent video on that very
topic that you can watch right here
after the theory's over
don't worry i'll link to it during the
end screen so you won't forget to watch
it the tldr of malthus's theory or
malthusianism is that quote the power of
population
is indefinitely greater than the power
in the earth to produce subsistence for
man
or as thanos put it it's simple calculus
this universe has finite resources
finite
if life is left unchecked life will
cease to exist it needs correcting
but thanos factored in something that
malthus didn't
and that is carrying capacity with
humans our carrying capacity of 11 to 12
billion comes less from the restrictions
of the environment and more from our own
economic behavior
the global birth rate has been dropping
since the u.n started keeping track of
it back in the 1950s
falling from 37.2 births per thousand
people in 1950 to 1955
to 19.4 births per thousand people as
recently as 2010 to 2015.
that is a huge difference and you can't
blame declining resources for it since
over the same period the gross world
product increased over 19 times from
about 4 trillion to about
77 trillion so what's the problem here
well it's infant mortality or should i
say lack thereof
it may seem strange that more babies
living would actually cause a population
to decrease but here's the thing
your great-great-grandparents lived in a
much rougher world than we do
they lived at a time where unfortunately
it was just very
unusual for all your children to live
into maturity each child that did live
however could help you work your land or
manage your
home when it was unlikely that you could
afford to hire much labor on your own
you could also marry your children off
for dowries or political capital and
because of
all of this it was socially advantageous
to have as many children as possible
however nowadays there are just far
fewer economic advantages to having kids
which is admittedly a terrific thing for
me to be saying when my wife is pregnant
but seriously it's true
there aren't dowries anymore if anything
your child is likely to cost you money
on the wedding
and the education and while they live in
your basement looking for a job and
speaking of that
time is another key factor here as the
amount of time that we spend raising
each child has historically trended
upwards if your medieval father didn't
show up to your pony league jousting
tournament because he was too busy
fighting the crusades or whipping the
serfdom into shape
literally and figuratively well that was
just expected but if your modern day
father here in 2018 misses just one
little league baseball game because of
his work you're gonna get yourself a
lifetime movie of the week
he was so neglected as a child we can
actually see this playing out on the
world stage today
where many of the most economically
developed countries populations
are stalling japan had record low
numbers of children
at just around 15 million this year and
in europe the average couple only has
1.6 children that's not even enough to
replace the existing generation
collectively this means that the human
population is no longer growing
exponentially like many of the
fear-mongering news outlets proclaim
in fact since 1960 we've had absolutely
zero exponential growth whatsoever we've
had an absolutely
linear growth and this is the crux of
thanos
plan you see if the human population
were still growing exponentially well
then thanos's plan would have only set
the world's population back by a single
generation or about 25 years but because
our birth rate is
dropping and our population growth is
linear it's a good
indicator that we've moved past the
midpoint of this logistic curve known as
the point of maximum
growth what that means is that humanity
is done growing at this accelerated rate
and instead we're moving towards a flat
no growth population in short it doesn't
really matter how many people live on
earth as long as we're able to sustain
our current lifestyle
so if you cut the population in half at
this period in time you effectively also
cut the maximum population in half
meaning that thanos's plan would
actually have a permanent
impact so for a guy who looks like a
linebacker who's taken one too many hits
to the face
he's actually really thought this out on
top of all this
in thanos model the scientific and
cultural advances that have been made
aren't
removed from the world and so the world
in theory continues forward at about the
same rate of advancement
just with a carrying capacity of 6
billion instead of about 11 billion
6 billion by the way fewer people than
we have on earth today honestly even
though i was researching this
i couldn't believe it i was a bit
skeptical so i kept digging you see
thanos employs basic laws of supply and
demand to say that when half the demand
is removed by removing half the
population
prices should plummet this seemed to me
like it was a bit of an
oversimplification
but believe it or not historical
evidence supports thanos in this
too now there's obviously no real world
example where half the population
literally disappeared in a snap but we
do have a very well documented situation
where about
a third of europe died in a matter of a
few years
the black death there are some very
interesting things that happened to the
european economy as a result of the
black death that weirdly
made some european lives better and i
can already hear the vitriol in the
comments let me make it clear no one
here is saying yay
black death woo what a great idea this
is all
in the name of social science and marvel
movies this economic history article on
the black death notes that the general
wages rose by
40 in the years following the black
death while at the same time
rents for property actually plummeted
since there were fewer people to occupy
houses or work land
this meant that the demand for houses
fell and as a result of falling demand
the price of homes followed suit since
people needed to farm less land to feed
fewer people land that was once needed
for crops before
was suddenly diversified into ranching
increasing the supply of manure
and meat which in turn increased the
output of the land that existed
and even further drove down food costs
food prices dropped about
15 on the whole in the years immediately
after the plague so lower food costs
lower housing costs and higher wages the
people that were left
kinda benefited from all of that death
thanos and his twisted brain could
conceivably call that a paradise where
those who remained
thrived who knows maybe in this
situation a millennial would actually be
able to afford a house
so are we looking at a potentially real
victory here under thanos's rule well
it's kind of hard to know for sure
because when it comes to economics there
are all sorts of dominoes knocked down
the line that can cause a massive amount
of blowback
with a huge global crisis like thanos's
snap and falling prices it changes the
picture for
a lot of these same issues for instance
with the costs of having a kid much
lower and a huge
depopulation of earth people would
likely feel a pressure to have
more kids than they currently do
potentially pushing the carrying
capacity higher than where it currently
is
as we jump start our growth rates again
china now less concerned with
overpopulation
would start to loosen their population
control laws as well as many of the
other environmental laws that may be
helping to slow the effects of things
like global warming today
and the rest of the world would probably
follow suits also
interestingly enough earth would most
likely close off its doors
its atmosphere space port things
basically it wouldn't let other aliens
in because you know the first few aliens
to make it to earth all tried to kill us
that sort of xenophobia would likely set
earth back in terms of becoming
culturally integrated into the rest of
the galaxy too bad you can't build a
wall around an entire planet
actually i think you can it's called a
force field economic solutions
aren't a snap literally or figuratively
the fun thing about this episode is that
it was a fun thought experiment
it doesn't matter it was simply a test
of math and statistics but at the end of
the day
human life is priceless killing off half
a population is never
a solution plus let's all face it
there's no denying that thanos is
definitively a mad titan because guess
what there is an easy solution here you
just snap your fingers
and double everything or why stop there
you make it infinite
seriously thanos you have yourself a
gauntlet of unstoppable power
think outside the box but hey
that's just a theory a film
theory and remember that wisecrack video
i mentioned midway through the episode
boom there it is on screen i love the
guys over at wisecrack and if you enjoy
these sorts of pop culture thought
experiments well then you're gonna love
their channel
this is their assessment of the
philosophy of thanos which is
insanely interesting so honestly do
yourselves a favor if you enjoyed this
video which
obviously you did you made it to the
very end of it click the button you see
on screen right now
give it a watch learn something new and
tell them that matpat sent you
give the video a watch if you enjoy it
give them a subscribe they're one of the
most deserving channels on youtube
producing some of the smartest content
out there at a time when honestly the
algorithm makes it really hard to do
smart educational content so show them
some love
and that's about it in case you missed
it here's my prediction theory on
deadpool which
we'll see if it comes true in the next
couple days and i will see you all
next tuesday